in may 2019 a small
counter narcotics unit was rolling down
a country road
in a rural part of sinaloa which was the
center
of the global drug empire created by el
chapo guzman
they were overcome by a pretty powerful
smell they were literally stopped in
their tracks and it's one of the things
that people on these counter narcotics
squads
are looking out for smelling out for in
this case
so they got out of their vehicles and
through a clearing of trees
they found five cauldrons
that were being used to produce heroin
and they also found
four jugs of a chemical called acetic
anhydride
that was made by a major multi-billion
dollar
american company and the product brand
was jt baker
and that chemical is the only thing
other than the sap
from opium flowers that you need to
manufacture heroin
and under international drug laws it's
one of the most highly controlled of
these chemicals
sold anywhere in the world except mexico
the great tragedy for me in
investigating this was the idea that any
american company
could be involved in that even if it's
unknowing
it really made us feel like we had to do
everything we could to
expose this situation and make it public
in the 1980s there was a flood of
cocaine production
from latin america into the united
states an epidemic of crack in new york
is now out of control and there was a
huge surge
in the use of cocaine and then crack
cocaine do you have no words to describe
how bad it is
i've seen young mothers with babies and
strollers
and small toddlers at their skirt tail
buying
crack in the neighborhood where i live
amid sort of like
a lot of concern and even some hysteria
in the united states about the cocaine
problem
the cia and the drug enforcement
administration in the u.s
made a rather embarrassing discovery
that about 95
of the chemicals that were used to make
cocaine
in south america for the u.s all came
from
american chemical companies behind
closed doors at senate offices on
capitol hill
the senate intelligence committee began
its investigation this morning
one of several committees that want a
out hearings in congress there was a
scandal
and it was a pretty swift reaction and
so there were
significant amendments to the drug laws
requiring chemical companies to take
responsibility for their sales
overseas and to make sure that from
start to finish
the supply of drug making chemicals went
to customers who had a legitimate
purpose to use them
and weren't diverted to the drug trade
the u.s aggressively pushed
international drug laws
around the world and virtually every
country has adopted
domestic and international controls over
these very same chemicals
there's a list called the red list and
that list
contains the chemicals that are of the
most concern and there are are the most
highly regulated at the very top the
chemical that is of the most concern
internationally and has been since 2001.
is a chemical called acetic anhydride
and it is the only
critical essential chemical that you
need to make heroin and that's why
it's it's number one on the red list and
it's number one
under international narcotics laws we
were trying to figure out knowing
that acetic anhydride was absolutely
necessary for making heroin and it was
strictly controlled
how the drug cartels were getting access
to it
[Music]
internationally acetic anhydride is
heavily regulated
for 18 years mexico avoided stringent
regulations
you know they said that it was too
costly for companies it wasn't necessary
in 2018 they tightened the regulations
but even with those tighter regulations
we saw that sale of quantities that
should have been regulated
went you know fell through the cracks
when completely unnoticed
regions where a lot of poppies being
grown
farmers have to resort to growing the
the plant
mainly because of poverty um you know
they're not either able to sustain their
families with the usual
corn or bean crops or they actually
sometimes get
threatened by cartel groups that require
that they grow them
on their on their plots
mexico production of heroin waxes and
wanes but
at its height there is a huge demand
from the cartels or acetic anhydride
because that's really the only
ingredient missing for them they have
the farmers producing their poppy for
them so
they just need to get a hold of some
jugs of
the chemical and then they're ready to
go
these chemical labs all over poppy
producing regions some of them get
seized by the government and then the
government snaps photos of them
sends them to the media the media puts
them up on their websites and with a
simple google search you can
see what these labs look like so i'm
scouring google looking for
chemical labs and and busts by the army
and i see a bunch of them and they
normally have
a lot of unmarked blue barrels or
unmarked bottles of chemicals
but i came upon one photo where i
actually saw there was a label and the
label read jt baker
i went through more searches and i saw
it on another photo and and
jt baker just kept popping up as one of
the only labels that you could actually
see
on the chemical in these lab busts so we
realized okay something's happening here
so jt baker was a century-old american
brand
that had this really good worldwide
reputation
for its purity and its purity and
control of its production
was a huge part of its marketing to
chemist at universities to chemists in
the in the pharmaceutical industry who
use it in r
d research and development labs it had
been bought the brand in august of 2010
by a company uh that became known as
aventur
from discovery to delivery scientists
and research professionals worldwide
trust avon tour they really had a strong
presence in the lab chemical market
worldwide
but especially in the americas their
operation in mexico
was a significant player for them in the
industry
[Music]
so as we started looking into this this
jt baker brand
we started discovering a lot of really
extraordinary things
sellers and distributors in mexico that
we spoke to
told us that it was incredibly popular
with the narcos
and the reason it was so popular was
because for the same reason that it was
marketed
for laboratories was its purity and its
reputation for purity
we found that the company was selling it
in these rather extraordinary containers
so there are 20 liter size containers
which is it's a pretty
substantial black plastic container to
keep the sunlight out
aventure had said that this specific
container
was the largest amount of chemical you
could get in a container designed for a
single
operator to be able to still use handily
now the norcos
absolutely loved these jugs they were
perfect
for the cottage industry nature
production of heroin in mexico
[Music]
so one thing we found once we sort of
studied the market in mexico
and studied aventura was that aventure
distributes in mexico through what are
called channel partners which are
essentially distributors
and by law they're only supposed to sell
acetic anhydride
to legitimate users
i started going down the list of the
channel partners and i just picked one
and went out to see them they were sort
of on the outskirts of mexico city
in a very industrial area i started
talking to the sales
manager and he basically said
you can buy it as long as you can pay
for it he didn't require any proof that
i was a legitimate lab
you know you could easily just walk in
and buy this stuff uh
quite cheaply actually and take it to
your um
your heroin lab and produce heroin with
ease
so that was pretty shocking to see
in november 2019 i was in mexico
reporting on the ground
and i went into this medical supply
store with a mexican colleague and we
bought a one
liter bottle glass bottle of jt baker
acetic anhydride
and the seller volunteered to us that he
could easily get us
an 18 liter jug with that one 18 liter
jug that you can buy
for about three hundred dollars you can
make about a million dollars worth of
heroin
and we also found that these 18 liter
jugs were being sold
on the biggest e-commerce platform
in latin america it's called mercado
libre it's huge in mexico
it's kind of a mix between amazon and
alibaba i guess you would say
and it was on offer from several sellers
online
publicly in mercado libre we weren't
supposed to be able to buy it unless we
were legitimate buyers
but we didn't have any trouble getting
it one thing we noticed
on the aventura products that we were
able to purchase is it said made in
mexico
in spanish right there
and we were like well that's interesting
because aventura has you know these
plants
outside of the in the us basically so
how can they say made in mexico
and it turns out that somehow they are
bringing
uh the chemicals the ingredients
and putting it into the jugs in mexico
in a facility they have in mexico
and it's actually produced by a
subsidiary
in mexico so it really is made in mexico
at least under mexican law
so that basically allows aventor and
conceivably other
companies to produce this stuff in
mexico which means they have to comply
with mexican regulations
everything was done in mexico to create
and sell this product
the company was able to say that it did
everything
perfectly legally under mexican law
because mexican law
was the only thing that applied because
mexican was kind of this island
unto itself in international drug laws
for the heroin making chemical so they
said of course that they hadn't violated
the law
that their sellers the distributors and
the retailers that they sold to
were responsible for who the end user
was
in 2014 alone more than 47 000 people
died from drug overdoses more than
any single previous year in american
history in addition to
cutting across virtually every
demographic in america
the heroin epidemic has cut across
virtually every region
of the country no urban part of america
has been more devastated by opioids and
by heroin
than philadelphia the city of
philadelphia has a
large neighborhood called kensington
it's an area that's become synonymous
with drug use
it's even earned the nickname the
walmart of heroin
the drug enforcement administration
routinely buys from undercover buys
and tests heroin from across the united
states
to do chemical analysis of where it's
coming from to determine its strength
its potency its purity and they also
track the price because that gives them
again a good idea of what's happening
the heroin that they've bought
in philadelphia which almost certainly
came from kensington
is the most potent purist heroine that
they've found
for sale anywhere in the united states
and the great irony of that
is that aventur which sells jt baker
branded acetic anhydride that was used
to make heroin in mexico
their headquarters is just 15 miles away
from the kensington neighborhood
the day that our story came out aventure
in consultation with its ceo and its
general counsel
decided immediately that they were going
to pull the product from across mexico
it was a pretty extraordinary move for
them to make and i think it was also
quite telling in terms of how concerned
they they were
with the evidence that we published
about how their product their company
was being used to fuel heroin production
for the united states
[Music]
you